welcome to the meditation on
procrastination and somewhat ironically
I've been procrastinating making this
meditation so we're all in the same boat
together so as with all meditations
posture and breathing makes a big
difference so I really encourage you
find a nice firm seat to sit on if your
legs don't fall asleep you could sit on
the ground as well but try to sit with
your back upright really good posture
breathe in breathe out a little bit
slower a little bit deeper every time
you could lay your hands on your lap I
like to leave them face-up and when
you're ready you can soften your gaze
and slowly close your eyes breathing in
breathing out now procrastination is an
interesting thing I'm not sure whether
we human beings are the only animals we
know of that procrastinate it's may be
worth some research for somebody to
figure that out but we clearly do it and
a lot of meditation is about becoming
aware of our thoughts and observing our
thoughts and realizing that we are not
our thoughts even though many times our
thoughts that seemed to control us or
even overwhelm us and so let's do that
let's try to observe those thoughts that
are making us put off something that we
know we need to do why do you think you
are putting that thing off I'll tell you
what it happens to be usually for my
experience it usually is I'm afraid to
start because I might realize it's
harder than I expected or I might not do
as well as I expected or I might make a
mistake maybe
yeah I don't think I'm prepared enough
to start another way to think about it
is we're getting too caught up in the
outcome versus enjoying the journey or
enjoying whatever the thing is that
you're putting off coz that's just a
part of this fun experience and so I
find that when I tell myself self define
yourself by the action not the outcome
don't define yourself by whether you
succeed or fail define yourself as
making the effort showing up and
enjoying it
laughing at yourself laughing at this
mystery that we call life and just
putting one foot in front of the other
and realizing it's not so bad and then
you could put the other foot in front of
that one and keep going and slowly but
surely you realize that you're making a
lot of progress and the more you make
that progress the more that you actually
enjoy it
especially if you're not between hit in
a last minute and now I'll give you
about a minute for you to repeat
something in your mind that can
hopefully short-circuit any of those
thoughts that have been keeping you from
taking action for the next minute or so
repeat to yourself that you really enjoy
taking action you're lucky that you're
in a position to be able to take action
the outcome it is what it is you enjoy
action you are lucky to be able to take
action the outcome is what it is keep
thinking that for the next minute or so
and I'll be back don't worry
all right so when you're ready really at
your own time just become a little bit
more aware of your surroundings a little
bit more aware of your body a little bit
more aware of your breaths and slowly
open your eyes and so I'll finish with
one last tip sometimes we put something
off because it just feels big or
overwhelming and what I like to do then
is say hey let me just put 20 minutes
towards it and see where I am at the end
of 20 minutes if I didn't make any
progress no big deal it was just 20
minutes but if I did make some progress
great I did the 20 minutes I deserve a
break if after a five or ten minute
break I'm ready to put in another 20
minutes awesome if at the end of the 20
minutes I want to keep going
I shouldn't stop myself I should keep
going but when you view things as hey
I'm just committing 20 minutes to
something it doesn't feel as
intimidating you just own it you say hey
I can do anything for 20 minutes and I
can enjoy anything for 20 minutes and
then you'll want to do it
put on a smile on your face and own that
action and not only will you make
progress but you're gonna have a good
time and so take it with that playful
mindset enjoy it smile and just get
started and I think you'll find you'll
be procrastinating a lot a lot less